If Velcro
had been invented first...
-Yeah?
-...would there be zippers?
You know, it's a really...
It's really a deep question.
Thank you very much.
I'm very excited.
But there's a...
There's...
You see?
Have a seat.
Please welcome
our guest here tonight.
Learn a little something
every day.
When you're bipolar, you have
a potential to ramp up,
and it could take it to a point
where you start acting erratic,
as TMZ would put it.
Were you ostracized
in high school?
No, we'd be on dates
with our boyfriends,
and run into the bathroom
and make out,
and go back
to our boyfriends.
I think I've had that
happen to me.
Going to so many auditions,
I've been told,
"You're too black," "Too light,"
"You're too ghetto,"
"Not ghetto enough."
I've been rejected all my life.
We all have
contributions to make,
and we all have to look
at ourselves and say,
"How do we connect
over our humanity?"
And then,
"How do we create equality?"
I was a smaller kid.
Struggled at school.
I was bullied
up until that point,
and I get in the car, and...
I was good at something.
Did you have a moment
when you knew
what you were gonna do?
-Mind if we talk about this?
-I'd love it.
That's fairly provocative.
What happened there?
Yes!
Is there anything
we haven't covered?
No, I think we covered
a lot more
than I even intended
on covering.
Have you ever done
one of them ancestry things
-or whatever, the DNA test?
-Yeah.
I wanna know if you're related
to anybody
from the North Pole.